the last few minutes we've received this  photo of nine-year-old olivia who was  shot dead late last night a beaming  smile there tributes have been flooding  in from family and friends but we now  have a statement from olivia's head  teacher from mark mary's catholic junior  school this is from rebecca wilkinson  she's paid tribute to the nine-year-old  she said olivia was a much-loved member  of our school she had a beautiful smile  a lovely sense of humour and a bubbly  personality she was kind hearted and  would go out of her way to help others  she added  she loved to perform and recently  participated in the school production of  the wizard of oz  olivia will be missed greatly by staff  and children  at the school